he sees as is the usual hour for S&P
partly depend money more ? oh gotcha
sorry woody see who was a very
interesting person for our pollito
beautiful rosy person phone and
incurring am singer so the fence around
thank you for the invitation for the
conference it's a pleasure to to speak
to so excellent audience I have to
stress this the topic of Polish Ukraine
relations during the Second World War is
the most controversial and
methodological a topic I think of the
post-war history during the communist
regime the public open our knowledge of
Polish people was shaped by books by
younger hard head but prueba and chess
hospital ski in those books bandits of
own oopah always kill innocent poles
yukia Ukrainian are always treacherous
and extremely cruel what is important
the events described in those books took
place on the territory of post-war
Poland but never in hanya or Eastern
Galicia regions which were part of
Soviet Ukraine simultaneously the topic
of anti-polish action of OPA in vilonia
and eternal Ganesha was prohibited by
censorship as a result in the Polish
popular remembrance open mass murderer
was transferred from bulimia and easter
garcia to get sad and Laberge tisna
Eastern Robert stresemann thanks to it
polish communists to show the visceral
action as the only effective way of
liquidation of open network only after
1989 has it been possible to study
polish ukrainian relations out of the
influence of the censorship immediately
afterwards many book on that on that
appeared on the market polish
historiography after 1989 was largely
side shaped by the influence of aerial
literature simultaneously there were
some books published which showed a
different approach we already have a lot
of articles of the historiography of
Polish Ukrainian relations in the US 19
39 38 the most available of which I find
those by Jacques Malika and answer round
server I must admit that this article
that in this article by Polish this
during this conference by Polish
historiography I mean all works
originally published in Polish and which
formerly for scientific criteria the
only topology of Polish history of it is
the one created but by Jacques nautica
he distinguished for friends revisa
mystic traditional